قبل ثلاثه ايام اصابت ضربه شقه انجلينا
[موسيقى]
كان فيها سرير هناك كبير غطى زجاج كل شيء
وانهار الحائط باكمال
لم تعد انجلينا وصديقها مكسيم يحتملان
العيش في هذه المدينه
الى تركيبات العائله ضربه اخترقت هذا
المبنى افراد عائلتها كانوا في الخارجو
اما من كانوا يحتمون في القبو فقضوا هناك
المدينه
ان يتمكنوا من الاتصال بناء
[موسيقى]
الشاب قبل المغادره
البارحه كنت ابكي الامر لا يحتمل لا اريد
ان اغادر لكن لا يوجد عمل
الوجه
على بعض 260 كيلو متر غربا هناك سيبدا
انجلينا فصلا جديدا من حياتهما بانتظار
عوده الهدوء لكن اثر قصف جديد تذكرهما بان
الابتعاده قد يطول
المعارك المستمره وظروف الحياه بالغه
القسوه تدفع بالمزيد من المدنيين الى
الخروج من مدينه محمود من اصل 70,000 شخص
كانوا يعيشون هنا تقول تقديرات ان ما بين
2005 الاف شخص فقط في المدينه